and I'm in the brain mind and
Consciousness program it's really unique
to find an organization that has a World
Vision and also an interdisciplinary
Vision that isn't outcomes based they
really allow you time and funding to
explore and be creative you see far has
changed the way I look at impact it's
beyond purely academic impact it's also
really important to think about the
social impact of your work
so that's been profound it's shaped the
way that I view science the way I view
myself as a scientist as a part of
society and the contributions that we're
meant to make with our science to
society another unique aspect of seafar
is that you also don't just build
networks you build friendships it was an
early career academic it's been
incredible to to build networks for
future ideas and and future
collaborations but also have this you
know close circle of friends to actually
work with and to improve your science
and science for society